[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend in allen wer soll das noch
bezahlen
das ist die frage die über diesem land
steht und über den kommenden monaten
wenn alles teurer wird speziell das was
zum leben essentiell ist dann müssen
auch die löhne steigen sagen die einen
und das klingt sehr logisch moment mal
so etwas könnte auch nach hinten
losgehen wenn nämlich die preise dann
erst recht weiter steigen sagen die
anderen und auch dafür gibt es argumente
die lösung jetzt ein arbeitskreis weil
das aber zu banal klingt und weil es in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
durchaus ein historisches vorbild dafür
gibt nennt sich das konzertierte aktion
gewerkschaften arbeitgeber und regierung
suchen gemeinsam nach schritten um eine
schwere wirtschaftskrise abzuwenden das
war damals so das ist es heute wieder
andreas linke
stahl zum glühen bringen um ihn herum
formen zu können am ende stehen teile
für pkw und nutzfahrzeuge bei bw
umformtechnik im schwäbischen ort
rosengarten ist der energiebedarf
sichtbar und spürbar
dessen anteil an den kosten hat sich
zuletzt verdoppelt
40 millionen umsatz
pro jahr und hektar 7 prozent waren
ursprünglich unsere energiekosten und
mittlerweile sind mehrere richtungen 13
14 oder auch 15 prozent die hoffnungen
des chefs sind klar ein modell zur
deckelung der energiepreise das gebe
planungssicherheit und die belegschaft
auch sie wünscht sich stabile preise
wir bekommen gelder preis also
lohnerhöhungen die wir dann in drei
monaten nicht mehr spüren ich meine wo
soll es denn hingehen die politik muss
reagieren und politik wirtschaft
gewerkschaften wollen reagieren
bundeskanzler olaf scholz spricht von
einem vielversprechenden auftakt der
sogenannten konzertierten aktion vom
unterhaken da sind die
gesellschaftlichen gruppen dabei
insbesondere die energiepreise sei es
für unternehmen oder die bürgerinnen und
bürger waren ein thema die energie
steuer und letzte geld können gute hebel
dafür sein dass in den griff zu bekommen
so bekommen wir schon gemeinsam eine
entlastung hin löhne sind aktuell kein
inflationstreiber
überraschende einigkeit denn auch die
gewerkschaften sehen aktuell nicht die
gefahr einer lohn preis spirale die die
inflation anheizt sie befürworten
ebenfalls dass wir allerdings sehr
deutlich und sehr dringend darüber reden
müssen wie die energiekosten tatsächlich
gehandelt werden können für die privaten
haushalte ebenso wie für die betriebe
die erste konzertierte aktion entstammt
den sechzigerjahren der lange
wirtschaftsaufschwung nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg stoppte
wirtschaftsminister karl schiller und
herbert giersch der damalige chef des
kieler instituts für weltwirtschaft
prägten den begriff der konzertierten
aktion doch bald spätestens mit der
ölkrise der 70er jahre zeigte sich immer
stärkere einflüsse von außen erschwerten
den erfolg massiv eine kieler
wirtschaftsforscher erinnert sich wir
sind allein ähnlichen situation wie in
den 70er jahren auch da haben wir
zunächst geglaubt die alten preise game
zurück das heißt wir würden weiterhin öl
so billig kriegen die von 173 das für
ein großer irrtum da hat man vieles
laufen lassen
und heute haben wir viel gelernt aber
die geldpolitik liegt jetzt bei der
europäischen zentralbank
und wie sind noch stärker vernetzt
globalisiert es bleibt also schwierig im
herbst wird die aktuelle konzertierte
aktion ergebnisse vorliegen
fragen dazu noch an den cdu fraktions
vize jens spahn nachher bei uns mit wulf
schmiese im heute-journal update in der
ukraine macht russland weiter boden gut
die russischen truppen treiben ihrer
offensive im osten massiv voran nach der
einnahme der strategisch wichtigen stadt
lässig attackieren sie jetzt weitere
städte der russische präsident wladimir
putin erklärte den sieg über die region
luhansk nach angaben des ukrainischen
regional gouverneurs ist die
infrastruktur der von den russen
eroberten stadt les cayes zu 90 prozent
zerstört nur noch ein zehntel der einst
100.000 einwohner sei noch da
im osten der ukraine wird erbittert
gekämpft in anderen teilen des landes
träumen sie von der zukunft und auch auf
einer internationalen konferenz in der
schweiz geht der blick nach vorn da geht
es um hilfe für den wiederaufbau
klar ist die ukraine wird über jahre
viel geld brauchen sie wird mit der
forderung nach umfassenden reformen
konfrontiert sein und sie wird menschen
brauchen die anpacken die zumindest sind
schon da wie luck wald zeigt
seit einer woche arbeiten die handwerker
der ukrainischen hilfsorganisationen
doppelbett auf dieser baustelle in
epping bei kiew 20 von 300 freiwilligen
die sich nach kriegsbeginn spontan
gemeldet haben und zu helfen
ich bin mit meiner mutter von nicolai
hergekommen sie musste ins krankenhaus
aber nikolajew ist unter schweren
beschuss und die meisten kliniken
geschlossen die warteliste ist lang
die baustelle ein fünfgeschossiges
wohnhaus wurde von einer rakete schwer
getroffen gas und wasser gibt es nicht
strom nur stundenweise aber die helfer
wollen vor dem winter ein behelfs dach
für die verbliebenen bewohner herrichten
das problem wird die heizung im winter
dächer oder fenster kannst du schneller
setzen heizungen nicht das braucht zeit
die haben wir nicht
im nebenhaus konnte tamara im märz
gerade noch fliehen bevor die russen in
die stadt und ihre wohnung eindrangen
ihre letzten ersparnisse sind weg jetzt
versucht sie irgendwie über die runden
zu kommen
ich habe einen kleinen kocher damit
koche ich das wasser vom hahn draußen ab
trinkwasser muss ich sonst kaufen im
supermarkt rüben
seit vier monaten kämpft präsident
selensky unermüdlich um internationale
aufmerksamkeit für sein geschundenes
land und meer waffenlieferungen um geld
viel geld 750 milliarden dollar so die
schätzung seines premierministers
braucht die ukraine um die kriegsschäden
auszugleichen schäden wie diese
brennende kraftwerke und zerstörte
raffinerien teil der russischen
kriegsführung für den chef des
staatlichen energieriesen naftogaz juli
wie tränke ein großes problem noch
liefert russland trotz kriegs gas in die
ukraine
wenn auch nur sehr wenig für den winter
dürfte es kaum reichen
wir brauchen humanitäre hilfe zum
beispiel zur finanzierung von energie
käufen auch direkte gaslieferungen
bis zum winter kann der landwirt was sie
nicht warten er muss bald den weizen
einholen ein lebensgefährlicher job nach
dem abzug der russen
da liegen jede menge minen und granaten
im feld sie haben schon ein paar dutzend
gefunden auch viele krater
dann zeigt er uns was von seinem
geländewagen übrig blieb nachdem der auf
eine mine fuhr was die latte glück und
lag nur vier wochen im krankenhaus
jetzt fährt die angst immer mit auf den
acker
die klimakrise ist längst da und selbst
denen die immer wegschauen wenn
korallenriffe zugrundegehen regenwälder
sterben und halb sydney unter wasser
steht fällt es zunehmend schwer das noch
zu leugnen in den italienischen
dolomiten haben sieben bergtouristen
einen ausflug zum marmolada gletscher
mit ihrem leben bezahlt 14 weitere
werden noch vermisst die schreckliche
vermutung auch sie sind tot das war kein
unfall keine unachtsamkeit keine
harakiri aktion den touristen ist die
tatsache zum verhängnis geworden dass
ein gletscher den temperaturen einfach
nicht mehr standhält annette hilsenbeck
mit mehr
ein trümmerfeld aus eis und geröll 10
bis 15 meter hoch hier suchen die
bergretter weiter nach toten und
vermissten mit hubschrauber und drohnen
und im tera ein riskantes unterfangen
jederzeit könnte sich vom gletscher
weitere eisblöcke lösen wie gestern ein
teil des mammut letters wieder
abgebrochen eine gewaltige lawine aus
eis schnee und felsbrocken donnerte
bergab sie reißt alles mit sich auch
zwei bergsteiger gruppen bergretter
finden mehrere tote verletzte werden in
umliegende krankenhäuser geflogen unter
ihnen ein mann und eine frau aus
deutschland
die leute vor uns wurden weggefegt sechs
oder sieben begannen zu rennen aber es
war so schnell wie eine schwarze wände
wir wollten dieses laute geräusch und
haben uns in eine hütte geflüchtet dann
kam die lawine immer waren der seite
vorbei
eine katastrophe wohl den klimawandel
geschuldet der gletscher toppen brach ab
nach wochen ungewöhnlich hohe
temperaturen am berg marmolada war
gestern der rekordwert von 10 grad
gemessen worden
das jahr 20 22 ist insbesondere im süden
auch deshalb sehr außergewöhnlich weil
die schneemengen des winters
unterdurchschnittlich waren die
eisfläche sind also sehr früh schnee
frei geworden und es ist zu erwarten
dass sich die gefahrensituation im laufe
dieses sommers noch erheblich
verschärfen wird denn durch hohe
temperaturen und ein strahlung entsteht
schmelzwasser durch das es zu hohlräumen
kommt der gletscher kann ins rutschen
geraten das eis bricht heißt fels und
schob mit sich
die derzeitige situation auf den alpen
gletschern ist historisch noch nie
dagewesen das heißt wir können auf
keinen erfahrungsschatz zurückgreifen
weder in der beurteilung welche stellen
tatsächlich gefährlich sind noch an
diese ereignisse zu erwarten sind ich
gehe davon aus dass wir am ende der
saison sehr viel mehr wissen und diese
art von gefahren wesentlich besser
einschätzen können die steine und
eislawine hat opfer hunderte meter
mitgerissen sie zu identifizieren wird
den helfern kaum möglich sein heute
versuchen die bergretter aus der luft
per handy ortung vermisster auszumachen
und erwähnt doch etwas schroff nach
einer solchen katastrophe mit solchen
unglaublichen massen liegt die hoffnung
noch menschen lebend zu finden ehrlich
gesagt fast bei null und damit schien
anderen seite
trotzdem sie wollen alle opfer finden
und bergen laut behörden könnte das noch
wochen dauern
auch vor dem höchsten berg der welt
macht die klimakrise nicht halt der
mount everest hat nach neuesten
forschungen in den letzten 25 jahren
etwa so viel eis verloren wie sich dort
normalerweise in einem zeitraum von 8000
jahren ablagert
nimmst das jetzt mit durch die weitere
nachrichten welt an diesem montag in
kopenhagen ist nach dem amoklauf in
einem einkaufszentrum der mutmaßliche
täter in eine geschlossene psychiatrie
eingewiesen worden dort muss er seine
untersuchungshaft verbringen das ordnete
ein gericht nach der anhörung an die
polizei hat einen terrorhintergrund
ausgeschlossen das motiv des 22 jährigen
dänen sei aber weiterhin unklar in
videos soll der verdächtige mit waffen
posiert haben er wird beschuldigt drei
menschen getötet und 30 weitere verletzt
zu haben vier von ihnen schwer
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
sich mit den kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen über die abrechnung von
corona tests geeinigt diese hatten die
neuen test regeln als zu bürokratisch
kritisiert und zunächst die abrechnungen
abgelehnt lauterbach stellte jetzt klar
test berechtigungen und mögliche
auffälligkeiten würden von den
ordnungsbehörden der kommunen überprüft
in den usa protestieren die menschen
erneut gegen polizeigewalt nach dem im
bundesstaat auch heuer wieder ein
afroamerikaner durch dutzende
polizeikugeln getötet worden waren am
vierten tag der proteste kam es jetzt zu
zusammenstößen mit sicherheitskräften
zuvor hatte die polizei body cam
aufnahmen von der verfolgungsjagd
veröffentlicht mit der sich der
unbewaffnete 25-jährige einer kontrolle
entziehen wollte die beamten gaben an
sich bedroht gefühlt zu haben
bei einer parade zum nationalfeiertag in
den usa sind in einem vorort von chicago
mindestens sechs menschen getötet worden
mehr als 20 weitere wurden verletzt der
mutmaßliche täter ist noch nicht gefasst
er soll von einem dach aus auf menschen
geschossen haben der tatort wurde
weiträumig abgesperrt besucher und
parade teilnehmer versuchten sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
schon wieder und immer noch
happy birthday america traut man sich
kaum zu sagen angesichts dieser
nachrichten es ist nationalfeiertag vor
53 und in die glückwünsche mischen sich
mehr als einige sorgen auch jenseits
eines weiteren todesschützen heute es
geht auch um mehr als den riss der schon
lange quer durch die us bevölkerung geht
es geht um grundsätzliches
es gibt beobachter die warnen es geht um
die demokratie
anlass sind gar nicht mal nur die
wütenden verschwörungs gläubigen auf
amerikas straßen an das ist das was aus
einem marmornen prachtbau auf dem
kapitolshügel in washington zu hören ist
dem tempel des rechts wo das oberste
gericht der usa ohnehin mit erheblicher
machtfülle ausgestattet sich gerade
massiv einmischt so sehr dass manche von
einem justiz putz reden aus washington
annafest
amerika gedenkt seiner unabhängigkeit
und den haben hier ihren anfang mount
vernon der sitz des ersten präsidenten
george washington
für traditionalisten wie den veteranen
thema keystone der besuch hier heute ein
absolutes muss man kann nicht den
unabhängigkeitstag feiern ohne hierbei
george washington am mount vernon zu
sein
und wie steht es um amerika an diesen
tagen nachdem herauskam dass der sturm
aufs kapital von krampf und langer hand
geplant war wir haben schon schlimmeres
erlebt das war doch noch nicht mal ein
aufstand ein aufstand dass es wenn
waffen und kanonen am werk sind und dass
ein plan gibt der größer ist als das
kapital gebäude zu beleidigen und dann
fügte er hinzu man müsse nun daran
arbeiten dass amerika stark bleibe so
wie es der oberste gerichtshof geradezu
ortswechsel flussabwärts 20 meilen
entfernt der oberste gerichtshof wo
kopiert von dem stranden hier wurden in
den vergangenen tagen weitreichende
entscheidungen gefällt das waffenrecht
wurde gelockert dass liberale
abtreibungsrecht gekippt und die
entscheidungsbefugnisse der klimaschutz
behörde wurden massiv eingeschränkt
durch die von schwamm gesetzt die nun
mehrheitlich konservative richterschaft
trumps erbe ein staatsstreich
gericht das ist ein putsch von tram die
richter sind absolut parteiisch das ist
ganz offensichtlich sie haben einen
langjährigen präsident voll umgestoßen
und zwar auf der grundlage ihres
moralischen bewusstseins und nicht auf
der grundlage eines rechtlichen
präzedenzfall
doch die frauen wollen nicht bloß
zuschauen wie die rechte für die schon
ihre großeltern kämpften nun kassiert
werden so rufen sie am
unabhängigkeitstag den kampf und die
demokratie aus weiter auf die andere
seite des flusses anacostia einer der
ärmsten stadtbezirke die
kriminalitätsrate 200 prozent höher als
im nationalen durchschnitt die
feierlichkeiten um den vierten juli sind
traditionell familienwochenende bei den
nun und was beschäftigt sie am
unabhängigkeitstag
wir zählen die ganze zeit wir machen uns
keine gedanken darüber was los ist
schießereien und all das
familienoberhaupt anthony moon
pensionierte buchhalter sieht das anders
als alter demokrat ist er empört
das ganze land ist verwirrt nun ich
sollte nicht sagen das ganze land aber
die mehrheit des landes ist verwirrt
weil wir jetzt von einer minderheit
überstimmt wurden die die mehrheit
darstellt im obersten gerichtshof
sie versuchen die freiheit
einzuschränken und das hier zu einer
diktatur zu machen das ist aber nicht
amerika
seine 18 jährige enkelin ist besorgt
denn es sei ihre zukunft die da auf dem
spiel stehe es ist als hätte man die
büchse der pandora geöffnet was wird
noch kommen
was wird noch kommen wie weit wird der
oberste gerichtshof gehen die
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe könnte
beschnitten werden und auch das
wahlrecht steht zur debatte
ja was wird noch kommen ist die frage an
hämmerte wissen und sein amerika
komponenten genannt elmar genannt
abtreibungsrecht klima politik jetzt
eine kern grundsätze der demokratie das
wahlrecht da geht es um den rechtsstreit
nur versus harper über den der supreme
court im oktober verhandeln möchte was
genau ist daran so brisant also es ist
ein fall aus north carolina einem
bundesstaat und der oberste gerichtshof
muss entscheiden ob ein bundesstaats
parlament ganz alleine das recht hat
über das wahlrecht für die
präsidentschaftswahl oder für andere
bundeswahlen zu entscheiden also auch
für die kongresswahlen dann in
washington bisher war es so dass in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten dass ein
zusammenspiel war zwischen den
jeweiligen bundesstaats parlamenten
zwischen den gouverneuren in diesen
bundesstaaten und dann gegen gerichten
das heißt alles was entschieden wurde
und da lag immer noch einmal der
juristischen kontrolle und das könnte
durch ein urteil ausgehebelt werden und
wenn man sieht wie der oberste
gerichtshof in den letzten wochen
geurteilt hat geht es offenbar dahin und
das ist deshalb relevant weil in 30 von
50 amerikanischen bundesstaaten die
republikanische partei die mehrheiten in
beiden häusern der jeweiligen
landesparlamente halten und damit im
grunde genommen in sachen wahl machen
können was sie wollen und wie könnte
sich das ganz konkret auswirken auf die
präsidentschaftswahl etwa 2024 das
könnte bedeuten dass ich sag mal in der
extremen konsequenz ein parlament nach
einer wahl entscheiden kann dabei
irgendetwas nicht ganz in ordnung wir
akzeptieren das wahlergebnis nicht und
wir schicken einfach andere wahlmänner
nach washington und die wählen dann eben
einen anderen als präsidenten der nach
den umfragen oder nach den ergebnissen
der wahl tatsächlich eigentlich der
kandidat gewesen werde das ist ein
zweiter angriff es gibt noch einen
anderen in den einzelnen bundesstaaten
haben die republikaner in den vorwahlen
kandidaten für die ämter als gouverneure
und als innenminister
die auch im november gewählt werden
könnten und auch unter denen sind eine
ganze reihe die sagen die letzte wahl
wurde gestohlen und sagen auch sie wären
bereit wahlergebnis eventuell nicht zu
zertifizieren oder zu annullieren ich
glaube man kann sagen hier entweder hat
die amerikanische demokratie ihre
orientierung verloren oder es ist ein
umsturzversuch in zeitlupe in beiden
fällen nicht gut und werden gerade ein
erlebt im weißen haus dem das zur kasse
gekommen wäre herzlichen dank wir werden
auf den oktober gucken müssen und auf
das oberste gericht el mati wissen hier
läuft bei uns in der sendung vielen dank
und jetzt nochmal so gundula
mit den finanzmärkten die schauen mit
sorge auf die wirtschaftlichen folgen
der gaskrise jetzt zeichnen sich
staatshilfen für juniper ab einen der
größten deutschen energiekonzerne wir
fragen valerie haller an der börse was
genau ist da geplant noch gibt es keine
offizielle bestätigung aber aus
regierungskreisen heißt es dass der bund
einen schutzschirm für angeschlagene
energieunternehmen plant ein neues
gesetz soll es erlauben
schlüsselunternehmen gezielt mit
krediten zu unterstützen bis hin eben
zur staatsbeteiligung
wir kennen das prinzip von der lufthansa
in der korona krise hat sich ja der bund
an der airline beteiligt eben um sie zu
stützen juniper spielt als großer
gasimporteur eine zentrale rolle für die
deutsche energieversorgung seit russland
deutlich weniger gas liefert muss
juniper es anderswo teuer einkaufen darf
aber den mehrpreis nicht an seine kunden
weitergeben das bringt das unternehmen
nun in existenzielle not das gesetz
könnte noch diese woche bundestag und
bundesrat passieren danach wäre
finanzielle hilfe für juniper möglich
auch mit dem ziel immerhin drastische
preissprünge für gaskunden zu verhindern
die aktie von juniper ist seit tagen
schwer unter druck nach berichten über
den möglichen staatseinstieg rauschten
die papiere noch mal richtig bergab die
lage der energieversorger könnte sich
noch einmal verschärfen am 11 juli wenn
die jährlichen wartungsarbeiten der
gaspipeline nord stream 1 beginnen
möglich dass russland den hahn danach
komplett zu dreht auch deswegen macht
die regierung nun tempo um kurzfristig
reagieren zu können im ernstfall vielen
dank valerie nach frankfurt beim tennis
klassiker von wimbledon ist das doppel
kevin k wie jetzt und andreas mies zum
ersten mal ins viertelfinale eingezogen
das erfolgsduo aus coburg und köln
setzte sich gegen die briten o'meara uns
gab's gehe durch nächste gegner sind die
titelverteidiger max und pavic aus
kroatien der eifel krimi autor jacques
berndorf ist im alter von 85 jahren
gestorben seine bücher davon 22 folgen
der eifelkrimis verkauften sich sechs
millionen mal der gebürtige duisburger
lebte seit fast 40 jahren in der
vulkaneifel wo er seine krimis spielen
ließ und auch starb
nur noch 20 prozent aller korallenriffe
weltweit sind in einem guten zustand wie
diese besonderen ökosysteme gerettet
werden können darüber beraten in bremen
rund 1.000 internationale
wissenschaftler eine woche lang auf der
15 welt korallenriff konferenz zum
auftakt war bundesumweltministerin lemke
für mehr klimaschutz korallenriffe seien
von der klimakrise besonders betroffen
dringend seien nachhaltige maßnahmen
gegen die sogenannte korallenbleiche
coldplay das ist stadion rock vom
feinsten sagen die fans das ist
stadionrock vom gigantischen sagt die
statistik zuletzt also vor corona
122 konzerte auf fünf kontinenten
32 riesen-lkw allein für die bühnen
größer geht es kaum noch
und dann kündigt sänger chris martin an
wir nehmen uns jetzt mal zeit um
herauszufinden wie unsere tour
nachhaltig nützlich klimaneutral sein
kann oder so gesagt und viele hämische
kommentare geerntet und dann losgelegt
das ergebnis konnte man gestern sehen in
frankfurt am main claudio armbruster
[Musik]
wir sind keine vorbilder wir wollen
zeigen was funktioniert und was nicht
funktioniert wir experimentieren
was coldplay versuchen ist grüner zu
werden nachhaltiger umweltfreundlicher
dann solche shows so schön sie auch sind
sind umweltsünden
schon mehrere tage vor dem konzert wird
strom erzeugt durch solar- und
windenergie an mehreren stellen im
stadion und sie gehen originelle neue
wege
eine tour wie diese ist fast wie eine
expo für neue ideen es gibt zwei
kinetische tanzflächen auf denen die
zuschauer durch hüpfen und tanzen
energie für unsere batterien liefern
vielleicht kommt jemand darauf dass man
das auch in einkaufszentren einbauen
könnte oder auf gehwegen oder in schulen
überall wo gelaufen wird wir möchten
zeigen was mit neuen technologien
möglich ist wir sind hungrig nach neuen
ideen und dieser show ist eine gute
plattform dafür
die kinder haben spaß auf den fahrrädern
die neben den kinetischen bühnen stehen
und jagen so strom in die akkus für die
nächste show
die leuchtenden armbänder fürs publikum
bestehen aus kompostierbaren material
bis auf die elektrik darin natürlich und
jeder muss seine band nach dem konzert
wieder zurückgeben wer trinkflaschen
mitbringt bekommt wasser nachgefüllt for
free
es sind also nicht nur wir die band die
sich bemüht sondern das ganze publikum
wieder steuert etwas bei
ein teil der hohen eintrittspreise geht
an verschiedene
umweltschutzorganisationen
für jedes gekaufte ticket wird ein baum
gepflanzt bei drei ausverkauften
konzerten in frankfurt sind das schon
150 tausend bäume
ja genau aber wir pflanzen sind selbst
die show selbst 250 sauberer geworden
nach aussage der band das größte problem
jedoch dass die tour das unvermeidbare
reisen
damit können wenn auch mit den transport
auch das publikum muss jahren reisen von
dem thema müssen wir dranbleiben
das wichtigste für uns ist wir versuchen
unser bestes es ist herausfordernd und
noch ein langer weg
natürlich können sich kleinere bands
coldplay so ein teures
nachhaltigkeitskonzept nicht leisten
aber coldplay zeigen was möglich ist
[Applaus]
das war unsere welt an diesem montag
danke für ihr interesse und um 23 40
meldet sich wulf schmiese mit unserem
heute schon mal updates von uns allen
hier angenehm haben
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend wir starten mit einem
satellitenbild von heute mittag wir
sehen hier weite teile deutschlands und
auch frankreichs wolkenlos aber es gibt
da eben auch dieses wolkenband hier über
dem süden deutschlands hat sich jetzt im
verlauf des tages auch einige gewitter
wolken gebildet aus dem norden einige
tiefausläufer das ziehen wir auch auf
unserem regen vorschau film diese front
die hier über den alpen schleift die
beschäftigt uns auch morgen noch hier
oben haben wir diesen tiefausläufer
ansonsten streckt aber eben das
azorenhoch mit ruhigem und angenehmem
wetter die schüler zu uns aus so haben
wir eben heute nacht noch mehr wolken im
norden vor allem aber südlich der donau
noch schauer und teils kräftige gewitter
dazwischen ist es oft klar und dann
kühlt es teils in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen auch auf 8 grad ab unter
den wolken bleibt es bei 16 grad im
südosten morgen gibt es dann in der
mitte und im süden wieder einen warmen
bis heißen tag bei 25 bis 30 grad am
oberrhein an den alpen und auch im
norden ist es mit 19 bis 23 grad etwas
kühler im norden sind auch einige wolken
unterwegs mit einem westlichen wind und
einzelnen schauern im küstenumfeld in
südbayern sind ebenfalls schauer und
einzelne gewitter unterwegs die sich im
verlauf des tages dann aber in die alpen
zurückziehen und dazwischen haben wir
mal mehr quellwolken mal aber auch mehr
sonne im rest der woche wird nicht mehr
ganz so heiß trotzdem immer noch
angenehm mit 18 bis 26 grad und es kommt
regen auf und zwar in form einer front
aus dem nordwesten nachmittags am
mittwoch und das ganze legt sich dann am
donnerstag in diesen osthälfte des
landes